and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 35 it's
another glorious Sunday we are back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day we have
a lot of gaming news discuss so we're
gonna get right into it so let's
introduce don't usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the como Sh my brother
from another mother and the ha of the
young wolf my man Lord addict how are we
doing sir pretty good no doubt no doubt
very exuberant that's good and both the
good gaming Lord the solo game who lives
for the single player selfish experience
he's back to offline profile this week a
lot of work this week so I couldn't be
destiny like I wanted to I played a
little bit yesterday got some got some
iron banner in what's the lowdown what's
the lowdown right now it's my to Minnie
and mida multi right now but that's the
one yeah those are the ones I run with
in PvP but I'm a PV PBE I have using
like the like sunspot or something like
that
I forget had too much luck with hand
cannons in PvP like yesterday wait a
minute yeah not in a good place those
are some pulses better Devils I have a
base 299 so I'm trying to get but it's a
but is my doesn't matter you find it
really that's the big bigger the
community right everybody's upset
they will at some point so that's pretty
much what you've been rockin yeah that's
pretty much it a little bit more of
axiom verge you know oh I guess we'll
talk about that in Libya no doubt and of
course the access game Oh Lord who's a
man of his convictions them is nothing
less than that premium experience Oh
he'd love it
Lord King how are we doing sir it is so
crazy yesterday like it must have been a
box of holiday it was insane
get boxing on Fox you have boxing on HBO
yeah boxing on Showtime now I'm not
gonna give you all the neighbors will
give you the principal fighters it was a
KO fest last night you had chaos in
every fashion oh I wanted to get it like
every fight except for the Lauder fight
was a ko you had that happen tomorrow's
fight that was a KO yet the santa cruz
fight that was a kale yeah the George
Grosz fight that was a kid I was moment
to my UK people in London that was
fantastic over there and look really
good
let me get it father let it go James
guys then Stan you head um yeah the
Santa Cruz
Oh Oh what's this DeMarco debacle
knockout crazy tomorrow after that then
you get the Showtime fight Oh bro shout
out to our Haman I hate you your guard
sent to the sport of boxing you and your
your your ties to Showtime you guys have
put forth the greatest fights that we
have seen this year this has been the
greatest year for me
be alive as a boxing enthusiast because
you had the Laura fight fight in his
mentor all these people's fighting
mandatories you had the charlo fight
fighting Ericsson Lubin Aronson lubic is
a big thing in these streets
it was the up-and-coming he was a young
wolf that he was trying to set our log
Charlo knocked him out in the first
round with this uppercut hit his jaw
homeboy he was still swinging on the
ground it was it was it was beautiful
[Music]
tell you what you need is get into what
the Lord's have been planned and there's
a lot going on so let's start with the
young wolf himself Lord addict what have
you been playing this week pretty much
just destiny to this week nothing no
really no doubt shot out on that raid we
got to get careless done a lot of fun I
was so shut out or shout out to Revo
sand and beaming they are damn hilarious
and also uh Jess and good good run we
had some fun we've got to finish up cows
and uh those are what you call that lag
was a little crazy but we gotta get that
straight nap we should be all good so
Louis saw what have you been touching
you said little axiom which was
we couldn't place my cesta knees I
wanted to but definitely play more
accident birds getting a little further
than that than I did on the Vita version
um and then starting up stardew valley
but the star dudes one of those things
like if you're not paying attention to
it completely it kind of it kind of
takes over so I wanted to actually
finish axiom Birds before I really
depends a star do real quick because I
say Lord Kaiba to talking about star
like what is it just farming like I'm
still confused what this a it's a it's
an it's an RPG slash farming simulator
slash dating simulator it's a little bit
of everything in one and I think that's
the raw that people have like again
people we haven't gotten a new Harvest
Moon in forever we haven't gotten a new
earthbound in forever and these are
games that people you know old school
players kind of they love and they would
like to have a new version of and this
filled that void and again lastly like I
said last week is one dude who did it so
it's like you really want to support
this guy like it was all first came out
this game was crack for a lot of people
like it just it just hit every every
little aspect of that farming thing that
people like like breaking stuff down the
Minecraft site type stuff where you can
create different things from stuff that
you break down it just has that
addictive loop so I mean that's why
that's why as popular as it is fax fax
Lord King what have you been playing a
little bit of cuphead here and there
take up in small doses all the credit in
the world that he could sit then he can
go at it as hard as he went in it to
finish it I don't have that fortitude to
do that or the dexterity though you know
accomplish anything close to that but my
destiny days has been blending together
bro yeah and I didn't even know that I
had completed the raid with my other
characters so no facts that's what he
said it cuz oh yeah if it's been destiny
same here with me home shout out the
Lord cow and I got someone who kings
raptures we actually did a day fall
together it's got a coup so shout out
the calories people I believe is our
Lord Elite himself King rats we got that
done
oh by the way carry your miss I tell you
man sound like um Tommy from power I've
got to tell you that he do let's
everybody to jet you're like no
disrespect I love Tommy four-bar like he
literally says I was needed to tell you
that laughter i watch pilot yeah no
Tommy is he's like literally covered
copy so we got a night for popping um oh
I want to shout out to my peoples on
first of all wove a brick blade man it's
a little switch joint it's a hack and
slash I want to shout out to my guy
Michael held and the whole team
I fully Illustrated I've been rocking
with those guys a while you know this it
was wrong arm was on a Nintendo Mindy's
showcase a while back Lou in the corner
kind of like they think like King think
like final fight mixed remember this old
EA game was hack and slash was real
bloody was called sword of Sudan yes it
it's like the local co-op beat them up
old school with in 1080p cel-shaded you
know it's really beautiful and the voice
acting is great just like the story they
got story is gonna be a little you know
80s 90 kind of girl for $20 for the $20
spot is a nice sweet spot that's a nice
thing why would I cut head wave so your
shout out to full beauty shot the wolf
oblate they gave me a lot of props for
ohm they're gonna be game and we're
definitely a fan of it so on yeah check
that guy out if you guys have a switch
and I believe it's coming to Xbox and
what you call ps4
I think switch gets the exclusivity
first or own a little joint so passing a
million sales
oh yes absolutely so of course we got
the last week's poll results are in
there too big polls and the people have
spoken so this deal with pull one so to
the question with the rut the rise of
loot crate's and gaining like for the
sastras origins shadow war
does voting with your wallet even matter
in a tight poll at 58% is the yes resist
loop boxes and make change the
resistance is out here they wanted to
happen it was really close you know say
coming in that second place 42% is the
know the Masters looks do the lay down
stay down and conform it was really
close so about poll number one I'm still
going to loss what do we would he feel
about that with the people's game I feel
I'll be honest like I agree you have to
resist resist a loop boxers but I'll get
into this more in my atopic but you know
there's some people whose response to
this is support caught the game and much
I they go we gonna get into that I won't
I'm so glad you brought that up because
I definitely want to get is a lot of
stuff on the streets with that so you
hold on to that once off because I know
he going like yeah I'm with you
good looking on adequate you got I think
they're losing a narrative here is you
know broke boycott and they can't
boycotting what the practices are in the
game you can still be part of the game
you know to like the game so yeah that's
when we get to that topic there are
facts we can expound on that no doubt no
doubt I think as an individual as an
individual it's it's in relevant I mean
you can you can not you know by loot
crate's that's cool but when it comes to
the old thing you're not the whole
industry and there won't ever be a whole
movement there's very few times in the
gaming industry's history where there's
been such a mass movement of people all
on the same page that actually matters I
mean it has some minimal effect and you
know but we will get into it this is a
good one this is so good love it
alright so poll to says we had to double
up
last week on to the question do we feel
bungee has over casualized the destiny
to end game trials I am gonna press
needs raid at the expense of the
hardcore base the winner and kind of a
smoking 76 drone is yes power line is
gone that group is upset they saying
it's called the cat's rise coming in it
only 30% was the no destiny to is more
fun and better now group so I bring this
again to the roundtable look goods think
about this do definitely they casual
eyes the game but I think it's better
for the overall brand the stuff they
casualized didn't really mean nothing in
destiny one it was just more of a mental
a mental thing like it took about what
they were called light load was it took
10 light levels to really make a
relevance yeah and if you get up to that
point you should be on equal terms
anyway so you know I get why people are
upset over but it's like look like
they're trying to let you play other
games like let them yeah
I said you say I think you hardcore
probably struggling with that because
we're so used to just playing doctor but
Dennis says destiny and not be finished
that's kind of new but that's a good
point
think about that I feel that it's great
that they did it that way um you can run
across a lot of people as three or five
that never did the rain and I like that
um that you can achieve that light level
without doing certain things you're not
locked out of certain things you don't
have people looking at you saying oh
what do you 3:05 you know or you 299 and
you need those extra light levels and it
can only come from the raid and maybe
you're not good an actor maybe you don't
have friends like that but the way
destiny is set up now they want more
people to group together they want an
MMO experience how they're delivering it
to you so
you know you have people and your
friends this is like your bread II I'll
run you through trials real quick you
want to do it you're like okay I am
banner this weekend which is lit this
weekend um it's been real it's fun
because I don't even play but I was
definitely I like the the way that
they're bringing other people in and
Cooling people know yeah it's a good
topic I mean real quick I'll just do
experiment like I agree I think overall
like a lot more technology like for the
health of the game it's it's good
overall that the casuals so to speak are
playing everyone's in and it's it's
popular but at the same time like I
think for DLC too they when they do kind
of raise the level cap again you know
I'm saying the hardcore needs something
that continually be invested I'm saying
so I think to convert to power level for
hardcore and convert that to weapons and
armor like this stuff from the raid
should be so legendary that when you see
someone that has it you know what they
went through for that we get from the
raid right right they need to definitely
need to take it make that the mark or
they need to feel special
those are the things that is going on
with the raid clothing and weapons let's
get it like previous games when you got
raid gear the raid gear and weapons will
have a perk that is makes them raid
easier Thank You shows your proficiency
and join the rape mmm
this year the clothing is just clothing
just cosmetic cosmetic to the point that
you can put on the helmet and this
helmet doesn't help you stay in the
water with the bathe days with
protection a little bit longer or
something so it's like little
things that it this ray it was thought
out on the execution part but the Devils
in the details and he's not he's not
abundant in these details because right
the clothing nor the weapons are
essential to the rate exactly a nice
congratulate because Bungie right now to
lack the weekly update came out I'm not
gonna get too much into your topic okay
but I know that came out and at least
for the first time they're acknowledging
it because if you look at reddit right
now the top five things is in games over
casualization things that they took out
systems that were there that were
already in place like Lord King is
saying when you got the Ray clothes each
section of the clothes whether the boots
it made you do something that helped in
the mechanic of the raid and I'm saying
and this year it's like where is that so
it's like this it's like the snowball
effect sort of all these little hardcore
things that were already there and
that's the one that they got right you
know I mean that for whatever reason now
these systems are gone and people are a
little kissy you know I mean I think as
the filthy filthy casual in the groove
people are coming from but I feel like
the the overall health of the game and
how long the game lives more
absolutely I do think there is a middle
ground like I said like we haven't got
stuff like you know voter glass quote
like the weapons you know they're cool
but let's be real here a lot of those
weapons are kind of wack that we get
from the rail I he you know it's
whatever but like at the same time it's
like you know the weapons had a themed
to what they were and you know they all
kind of look alike but it's just easy to
scout the scout rifle version of the
auto rifle here's the auto rifle version
of the
and you know they they they wrote they
ro slacked when it come to that and it's
like where is you know where is our old
fate bringer and where is you know the
gun see when you got something like that
you you wanted it but when I get
something like this I'm like why I just
needed it to have them all warning
I would hope they're like we talked
about yesterday how the game is gonna
continue I mean last week how the game
is gonna continue to evolve and I see
those things being addressed like I
would I would hope that they addressed
that in the prestige versions of either
like moving forward in the night falls
and then also in the rates that way you
have those mechanics in in the race and
in the night falls that the people with
a hard core used to and that way run get
the best of both worlds where I can play
you know a certain version of it and
then somebody would more experienced
somebody who wants something different
out of it can get play a different
version harder version of it and I don't
see where that would be a difficult
thing to do and I think you address both
issues in that way you know but from
like again I think I agree with you guys
absolutely making it more accessible to
more people is what the game means for
the long-term health like if you don't
have that people gonna fall off they
just just are I don't necessarily think
that like I don't like I do have hope
that they address these but to be honest
with you I'm really thinking they're
just gonna throw features that we had in
destiny one and expand expansions and
try to sell that like yes with people
that people are like we waited two years
from custom games just have it stripped
from us like a year like axe strike
strike specifically here like yeah what
happened to ohm strike streaks remember
two strikes cooling system that they
added at the end like all these systems
that like why are they not there on base
level unless anyone how they kept
bringing it Oh
after taking King they kept trying to
sell us old [ __ ] insane his new [ __ ]
yeah yeah I agree with them to an extent
that's the part with the hardcore could
be me I have to
agree with I know I agree with your
overall points offer a shout to fame
I love that I love that kite boxes on
his joint you know saying like I love it
that that part is fine all we're saying
is like Lord odda Cocina if there's
existing system that they already had
they're gonna try so to you know say why
isn't it at the base level it almost
feels like you're King it's like number
one the Madden's used to come out the
new man and come out and they have a hot
feature or the loss of each ant MLB the
show and then the next one you like
where is it like that was I like there
like there's no reason why I should be
taking up something that works you just
expand upon it and keep I mean you know
I can understand you know stuff like
prison of elders because technically
through lore it's impossible because you
the reef isn't even accessible anymore
but like when it comes to something as
simple as custom games why is that not
like anything better your game overall
why isn't that not there real quick is I
know we going on but it's funny even
said that as far as law because ready
exposed Bungie with the whole power
level things at iron banner they
basically said you know soft according
to the law of morality or right it's
supposed to be different from crucible
with your whole was supposed to
determine who's the strongest guardian
so power level is built into the law and
there they said that bungees that guy
gets their own
they know they know it's not it's it's
not player friendly but people are not
you know what here's a family here's the
thing if you ain't friendly towards iron
banner play crucible you scrubs know
what's funny is iron banner and destiny
one wasn't even that like hardcore it
was casual still it was crunch risible
sires was the hardcore PvP mode most
the thing about it is the more the more
hardcore you make the game the more you
isolate it from the average player right
well I get that but when you only have
three things that's that's you know
in-game content in game brampton is
supposed to be for the in-game Guardians
like the elite players
manat it's not so hard to have the raid
yeah
the raid the rate iron bed I wouldn't
even say iron banner let them casual
eyes the hell out of that I don't care
about the raid what is the new trials of
trials of the nine right trials of the
nine that's the only two things I don't
want casual eyes okay but you said it's
just like I'm gonna be real like and we
King we might have to go into your
target
photo like what is like I miss when you
go to your lineup before Ironman or
trials whatever and you see you know
came under its kind of trio - damn I
need this you know saying because it's
gonna bump my light up to help me be
stronger in said activity like it's not
it means nothing like it you know so
again it just got to find that balance
that's all I'm saying where they still I
think my solution is maybe bring it back
for like when destiny went wrong or was
it Osiris DLC comes out you know in new
trials in a new raid nor that bump the
light out level up make power matter
again you know I'm saying and hopefully
they can kind of rectify it that way
because like Lord addict is saying I
mean you still have regular crucible you
still have all these other activities a
standard raid but like the prestige a
channel desk is supposed to be for the
hardcore dimension that the entire
multiplayer every multiplayer mode gone
pretty much from destiny 1 2 3 it's like
we're you know where's the I don't like
the fact that I can make it brand new
Titan I can run inside I just I just
don't like the fact that there's certain
aspects from destiny 1 which obviously
destiny 1 was like 3 years long but like
why am i buying a sequel to downgrade to
upgrade like that makes no sense to me
so it's mean that we understand my kid
would you mind me put you to the front
of the congregation the fact that I left
my notes inside the car it's found to be
launched on a PC and I felt that would
those people that are playing on console
right now because console I've noticed
that something is going on that the
people are walking around aimlessly
we're really nothing to do so are those
people gonna jump to PC being it is a
fresh new face and you know the
resolution is higher the the frame rates
is higher are you gonna jump into a new
space where some people are you know new
to it and you it might be a new
experience for you is that one thing and
also the MPS MPD's came out on destiny
stating that it dropped 50% on
significant on dis verse page of
physical copies of the game now they
didn't say anything about digital copies
digital copies could be up for we know
right like it could be going up and I
think in this in our new world and video
games where everybody is digitally
downloading games and you know putting
it to roger because you really don't
want to get up and swap games we have
come become very spoiled I think are the
spoiled ones are we taking over now with
the physical you know pushing the
physical out I just want to stop sit
around table oh I'm gonna tackle the the
I mean I don't
really have a comment on the peasy thing
but uh I'll talk about the you know the
sales flop like I don't necessarily
think it's like quote-unquote spoiled
people I think it's who buys games like
destiny to on launch for the most part
the majority of the of the install base
of these games it's hard for us who are
the people that know about stuff like
digital sharing and who's mainly went to
digital the hard court so you know I
really think that you know people people
be still thinking that like the digital
sells it's only like 10 20 % of the the
install base not if anything I would say
it's anywhere from sixty to forty to
maybe even fifty fifty these days we see
publishers like EA saying that they had
a decrease they've made three or four
reports from saying they've had a
decrease in retail copies but their
actual digital revenue has surged
through the roof well this one this one
I got on it and I'm glad we were
tackling this because um this is this is
hot right now Michael Pachter jumped on
this first I believe couple of analysts
are financial analyst jumped on yeah now
let's get their hard and fast testing
two numbers are down 50% and physical
sales that's fact
like regardless to what now as far as
your point lord at it yes digital
doesn't make a point now I believe shout
out to my man from Forbes you know I'm
saying poor testing would get you on the
show I'm still on you baby I'm holding
you to your word
Noah Tassie in Forbes so on yeah pretty
much what he was saying investor calls
in 2016 like basically and then compared
to now in Activision in 2017 they're
saying that the UH the actual digital
sale revenue destiny one was about the
high twenty percent right they say the
destiny to did uses only the mid thirty
percent so that still doesn't account
right now now what he's saying though
now let's look at it competitively Tama
Destiny one when it dropped Xbox
360/ps3 remember those three huge were
part and they said at that time in 2014
they're so close to about 80 million so
now they're saying to ignore Kings Point
but fantastic saying it make the numbers
may not be as bad as what everyone's
saying from this standpoint right now it
is about 65 million ps4s maybe 30
million let's say Xbox one and PC are
also right and let's say pcs the biggest
thing in this equation is I do think
there's a huge streaming community and
they've all waiting for PC version right
and and the key what Tassie is saying is
let's not flip because he's a numbers
guy as well he's saying the PC didn't
matter it's a separate launch it didn't
remember their October they're coming
out not one or two weeks of shouting
most couple things right shout applause
why we won't get him on the show cuz
we're gonna have him all over that PC PC
launch as well and I'm like um I LP
Twitter guys they've been asking about
that because we want to see at it
because there's guys that are waiting
for the definitive version we all know
uncap frame rate that whole bit so do
you think of people that actually have
the will to wait for that launch for the
PC version because I'd like to I see a
lot of people that were like I'm gonna
stick to my guns and just wait a month
and they didn't wait a month anyway and
they four days later yeah later
interesting is very interesting to see I
want to get your thoughts feeling on
this as well too with the numbers coming
out and I know MPD's coming soon so
we're gonna have to look at two in terms
of the PC stuff yeah I mean absolutely I
know there's plenty of people like if
you're really into destiny you you're
one of those people that's you know
running multiple characters so if you
have a PC to run that'll run the game
then you're probably gonna be doing the
same thing on PC I just don't I see
people playing it across platforms and
it doesn't matter because it's just one
of those things like you want to get the
entire destiny to experience and if you
in if you're that invested into it
you're gonna play it so yeah you're
gonna see people even if they are
playing on the console version by now
they're 305 by now they've done the raid
they're like okay I'll go and do it
again on PCs 60 frames per second
I see plenty of people that have the
ability to do that actually doing that
um when it comes to the sales yeah it's
obvious like digital sales are becoming
are at the forefront now it's it's just
the thing like looking said like we're
lazy we're getting lazy we're spoil like
we want stuff in our hands we want it
right at midnight I don't want to be
standing on the line to pick something
up at midnight I don't want to do any of
that stuff
so digital sales it's obvious that
they're gonna be they're gonna start
increasing more and more and it's as
bandwidth for people increases as people
that more people have access to a sort
of uncapped bandwidth in terms of
downloading stuff because that's a big
problem United States like there are a
lot of places in the middle of the
country that have you know they have
decent internet but they're but they're
capped at certain things so you can know
if you download you know 50 gigs a month
that's a game you know what I mean
that's one game like so you know we
don't have thankfully they don't have
that issue here on the East Coast at
least thus far but if that's a real
issue but as soon as that stuff starts
rectifying it so we're gonna see the
digital marketplaces are gonna keep
increasing and these numbers are gonna
keep increasing in terms of digital so
and I think yeah I think the disparity
also comes from the fact that there is
no last gen version any more of this so
I PC is gonna pick up that slack once it
once it's out my next question song by
du haut let me bring it to the table
like how much do we think pcs really go
move out here like we really think it's
gonna have that chunk it got it's got
rave reviews I know King you know you
saw it at UH I think you know what I
don't think you'll come close the
PlayStation 4 says okay so like it now
again this is they go it's not it's not
doing the cuphead where it's doing the
Steam right it's doing do okay okay so
the bad on it now okay to release it on
Steam and actually see the numbers that
it can really achieve because you know
these PC elite guys they are really like
hell-bent on stayin like Steam
is a must like steam you stink though
that car you can't touch your stuff and
then it don't be you know up to snuff
like with the car people shouted up
leave jae-min for more press no I think
he had a product is like you're not
popping as it is like they they I
wouldn't say you know damage but they
slow down the Xbox brand to help the
Windows 10 gaming brand and it feels
like they have like half their foot in
the in that Bert in that Windows has to
pull out it's funny you said that shout
out to my boys Nora and the Xbox to
shout that just got happy birthday
everyone day Jays I know it's your
birthday don't talk to you that you want
to show us what I haven't went out there
with man what rain bTW you know saying
but um yeah like he made a good point
like what Atticus say he's saying like
Microsoft I believe it's not run by dxi
guys one of my mark self guys but
they've got one foot in one foot out on
that store if you're going to do it
you've got to go all-in and this is jazz
calling now so you know he's Todd you
know he's got his ear to the ground as
far as where no central so if he's
saying that he's like yo they should put
Mike Ibarra in charge of that division
because my day on the street I'm like
please don't anybody don't worry baby
don't want the responsibility but I mean
he would be a person I can be a perfect
candidate for something like that and
they gotta get down further pay what's
the PC launch date we got to get that I
was like October
get that down maybe a week or two I'll
get that exactly out there
yeah we see how that affects a rig that
can have that joint smoke shot out the
victor in the chat he was like um
according to jazz I'm saying that it's a
mess because it's run only by the
windows team so yeah mentally disabled
kid that you it's like I interest maybe
the windows team just isn't adaptable
you know the gaming brand because the
industry is a little bit weird than
every other industry like we're very
vocal there's not so many other
industries that that is as vocal as we
are you know I would say a good example
is like the football industry like their
fans are more vocal than gaming than
gamers but like it's like go to the
biggest it's like go to the biggest
competition on on PC which is steam and
it's like there's your goal like I see
the Windows 10 store now like if I load
it up now and it's like it looks like an
app off of much bone like this yes it's
like how the only game I see like in
like you know point of reach they scroll
down and click games is Windows
minecraft for Windows 10 and went to the
which card game boom everything else is
movies it NFL on Windows and you know a
creeper double-feature and I'm just like
look that's why no one likes your sister
exactly how many stuff out well you know
people say you can have it download
problems after like 20 gigs and got it
we download the whole thing again that's
what people are saying look how bad
people flipped out on Microsoft when
they did that update and did put the my
games and apps to the right I mean
seriously
people will flip out over that then you
may be done
stop having the people that don't sell
games design the game store for Windows
absolutely Tendo in the past like y'all
want to buy your whole company I highly
doubt they ain't talked to steam oh shut
up stop the Microsoft and Nintendo
playing nice they got a game round right
Nashville just cross-play give them the
reins weren't there two Lords I said
that would never happen
bro no no no we're talking about Xbox
switch you can't just throw allegations
[Applause]
just watching the police-station city
free when we were talking about the Xbox
Live service talking about doom on the
switch and I said it would be fantastic
if they have some sort of cross play
cross a feature because that way that
way people that had here we go now he's
remembering Xbox Live cards with every
switch like I don't use that beam to the
specific topic of a cross save cross
play thing both of you said that'll
never happen
[Laughter]
when I bring the soundbite next to me
when I bring the soundbite up
and you ride your Robin was gonna say
you know I wasn't entirely wrong I know
my article that was factual you are up
next you will talk about this triple a
new box situation like like coming to
door hits like bus backs yes sir
so my topic this week is continuing the
whole lootcrate conversation there's
been so much drama over the past week
everybody has a different opinion on it
and hopefully we we're kind of winding
down Lenny but I don't think so but
there was gonna be something more to
talk about but in light of all this
drama right what do we feel do the
expectations that we have as gamers for
Triple A games and that's single player
Triple A games multiplayer focus Triple
A games any sort of Triple A game are
the expectations that we have moving for
for what those games are in terms of
quality in terms of graphic quality in
terms of length of game size a game is
that reasonable to expect moving forward
without things like loot crate's
in place to have them make more money so
wait and then let's look at the
possibilities that could replace
something like a new craze because I
personally am NOT a person that likes
crates in my games unless I'm purchasing
them with something like with in-game
currency or something like that and it
gives me some
and cosmetic even in a single-player
game if it gives me something that makes
me stronger if I'm playing it in my
house and I'm not affecting anybody else
if I want to run around and destroy the
game that's my business you know no
doubt facts whatever the case max as
soon as it affects someone else and I'm
playing with someone else and it affects
that experience that's a problem um so
the things the things that I was looking
at you know what what can we do to kind
of stave this off can we accept paying
more for beta for games at a base level
no we pay we pay less for games now than
we ever have I will never but okay that
young horses mentality it's not a young
person's mentality I guarantee you if
they increased it to 70 to 80 they're
still gonna do look great great well you
know all that's gonna happen if they do
this nothing we're just gonna pay more
for the initial game and still buy some
grace that's literally all that's gonna
happen there may continue sorry back off
these developments they're just being
greedy mm okay so let's get into the
whole money thing let's get into this
get to the money let's get to the money
in the collection this is dry from
kotaku recently released the book called
blood sort of places where he goes
indexing the development yeah
indefinitely development of certain
games and controversies that happened
there in like you know the whole Naughty
Dog thing with Amy Hennig things like
that right so one of the big questions
that even people in the know like any in
the industry
and in terms of media in the industry
that don't really have a good grasp on
is budgets for games specifically how
much X game cost to make a lot of times
the developers and the publishers do not
want to divulge that information so what
he's been able to glean over years is
that there's kind of a magic base number
that you can sort of use to create a
kind of round roundabout number of a
moment what it costs well pretty much
the magic number is if you hit that
number it's like an automatic Ori
investment that's pretty much well but
it's something that you can use to have
an idea of how much again costing me it
could be above that it could be below
that but it's a baseline number that
you around about idea of what it is so
that number is $10,000
that number is $10,000 a month per
person working on the game right so
let's let's take let's take a game like
shadow of war shadow of war by monolith
productions it's about a hundred people
in that in that in that development
studio so you're talking about a hundred
people ten thousand a month that's a
million dollars a month right you
multiply that by a three year
development cycle that's thirty six
months so that's 36 million dollars
right
that doesn't include marketing so let's
tag on another ten million dollars for
marketing that's forty six million
dollars that they have to make back
right if they sell lets okay so you
divide that by $60 right it's a base $60
price point right
and now you're looking at something in
the realm of seven hundred and sixty
seven thousand copies they have to sell
to break even at that price point right
so right let's look at that price point
site so they have to sell less than a
million to make to break-even right when
you look at now they're not rested not
receiving that $60 $60 is not going back
to the develop piece of that that's
going back to developer that's a B you
have to remember at launch if you're
playing on PC you're probably getting
that game at a 20% discount from
somewhere you're always getting a
cheaper than you're not getting at a
$59.99 but the person that you you're
buying this from rather cd-keys don't
they buy these keys and bolt from the
vitamin know they're owned by these keys
in bulk not from not from the publisher
so how are they getting so many copies
and how they didn't call you to sell any
keys has always been kind of a shady
thing because they're getting like the
majority PC players don't support the
community community but I'm disabling
that number the number for them to break
even keeps exponentially getting bigger
because of how these games are sold that
how these games are distributed so like
I said it's not it's it's very easy to
say
made their money back in X amount of
time if you look even if you look at
cuff head cuff had sold a million copies
in two weeks in two weeks this is a
twenty dollar game right okay this is
two weeks that it took to get there for
a twenty dollar game there should be an
impulse buy for anybody with an Xbox or
PC it should just be an impulse buy and
it's not it's about marketing or
marketing through word of mouth and
anticipation from the hardcore fanbase
you know so good game so yeah Walter
word of mouth did because also the
streaming you to push that game heavy
was all over the place and everybody it
popped up all over everybody was
screaming this game everybody it was
everywhere or on the Internet
but as far as in the streets the casual
people knowing about it they had to
stumble upon it and Microsoft weird
store that doesn't pop up these hot
games on your dashboard that should be
there like a notification have you seen
an egg a cup at commercial have you seen
one I received one no yeah so it's just
that thing where it's like these games
should be selling more they need to be
selling more and fact of the matter is
that it's kind of unreasonable for us to
say that it's not easy to get to 2
million like 2 million isn't really it
is a difficult thing to go there and ask
with their tried and true franchises so
the thing is what else can we do to sort
of stable this lootcrate thing because
why is it on the consumer why can't they
just make better games so why you it's
just because the game is not of quality
what if the game is if the game isn't
someone to people people's expectation
is because the game was average let's be
real here like don't just not sell made
me a name me a bad godly critic game
that didn't sell well good games
the thing there's very extreme
circumstances when these do happen and
nine times out of ten it was on the
publisher and developer that did it like
putting Tomb Raider on the same day
fallout was their decision that they
thought was bigger than someone else's
and they lost mmm try out the cycle in a
chat Titan thumbing saw sunset overdrive
people say entire four to all I wanted
some points any chat that people I don't
want to I don't want to overlook as a
chat is real it right now like rap and a
CNN command made a great point as far as
they felt they can't agree with addict
as far as raising the base price they
don't feel would help eliminate that
issue we do not dude they would do both
they would literally do both hmm
yeah shot to be money as well so so the
key did is like okay we got to get down
to the meat of it right we trying to
follow the money right we trying to be
trying to get down we had a collection
plate going as far as this Luke 8
business and is it essential for the
development again that guy saw what
we're seeing with you is we're not
saying we need to you know break even
make more profit we're seeing oh oh [ __ ]
yo yo dude over there once you go over
there make them blue boxes what what if
they add into your defense where it it
becoming the seemingly becoming you
sovereign favorite word when you have a
single play game like a shadow it says
now granite you know a shout-out to all
BG people bring it to my attention I
guess last of us and uncharted made a
hack no crazy I'm not sure I did
you guys got to quote me on that so it's
not like it's a new path right we've
seen a lot of social justice warriors as
far as new boxes because as that Star
Wars name take the Star Wars name in its
name the battlefront have the same games
about the likeness let's see how many so
let's see how many more right so the key
baby comes down to back to the main
point which is is this
central to development do they
absolutely need this revenue and I'm
hearing mixing shout out to four times
with quarters clowns also want to shout
out on Matt piscatella from MPD when
clowns approached him in reference to
that he not specifically said that this
is the almost infer that this is not
essential to the development but it's
almost additional revenue so that's the
case because wiggle did or the boxes
they see these companies it's just
copycatting they see what these
companies are making and they want a
piece of that pie because I'm sorry you
know that bad company thing that people
all the time okay cuz I would anything I
could to make money the reason for being
is to make money get that did but see
that's me talking from a business
standpoint I'm a cat I'm a consumer I
don't give two shits about that so no so
now now now we're getting into that's
the way to make money and I understand
their way think you don't make it right
now the other thing is now let's bring
it back to the ethics down when you look
at like a Star Wars Battlefront to pay
to win with the loot boxes now
significantly give you a multi player
adage over so I don't I'm not most
likely going by it you know I'm saying
I'm not knocking anybody and that's the
other point I want to say is because I'm
seeing this attack mentality on the
social streets where if law King says
he's buying it
which sleeve and it's like not supposed
to do this like you know what to do with
his money
so that's another aspect we gotta talk
because and I'm gonna borrow from my man
and my man Enrique Brad I'm gonna go on
a little rain let's go first
Iran special let's go I have a problem
with people getting up on their soap
boxes and ascribing the word integrity
to something like to your to what you
choose to do what you choose to engage
with in gaming or not when you talk
about not when you talk about boycotting
a game because it has loop boxes and you
call yourself having integrity for that
that's a problem to me that's that's a
big word you're ascribing to a little
action like you you know okay let me
finish almost same thing goes for people
who say that about people who buy into
PSN Xbox Live oh I have integrity
because I don't buy into those into
those multiplayer paywall things have an
issue with that because integrity is a
big word when you talk about integrity
of video games talk to me about not not
not cheating in a multiplayer game when
you talk about if you tell me my game is
developed by a bunch of eight-year-olds
in a Burmese sweatshop I'm not gonna
play that integrity
my game all the process for my game
we're going to the Church of Satan it's
a big boy word to describe two very
small actions I would talk about video
games and rip into other people for the
decisions they make
listen everybody has a right these
things are gonna be here regardless
they're not going anywhere if you want
to speak with your wallet you want to
speak with your wallet don't engage with
those things that you deem to be
exploited I just don't do it to calm
eliminating the game I call the point I
want to finish the point because I'm
gonna forget it and then I'll solve
recession that's God yeah at the end of
the day we're all part of the same
hypocrisy we've all every argument that
we have a make can be looked at from a
different angle and somebody could find
BS today if you're telling people to
boycott games specifically mas my
feeling is you're not a real gamer
you're not a moon gamer my feeling is
cuz you're not you're not looking at the
health of the Hobby as a whole you don't
love gaming you love to play games but
you don't love gaming as a whole cuz you
don't care what happens to it moving
forward there's certain things there are
certain practices ya that you should
speak with with your wallet and not
engaging
that does not mean boycotting an entire
game because you don't want you don't
want an entire studio to fall you don't
want then let's be real here let's be
really if you're a fan of gaming if
you're a gamer and that is your hobby
you never want anyone to fail
so don't go sit up on your soapbox
you're not the person I want on the
soapbox telling me listen man don't know
I don't want to hear that I don't want
to hear I'm a gamer and I want platinum
to fail
I'm sorry I have to tell you it's funny
you know first let me go on let me say
something okay that read in the comment
section that are coming at me over my
platinum I know you guys besides
Bayonetta you know the franchise besides
that besides near autumn autumn you know
maybe one or two other games
okay fine a good game five [ __ ] games
one good game five [ __ ] games that's not
acceptable to me like you you're a huge
fit I gotta play this guy you said
listen your purchase affects me so our
purchase affections I have every right
to point out what you're doing isn't
helping game still I just want to know
how the purchase of another man's
product affects you personally if you
have an issue with it and you choose not
to support no doubt I respect that
fusion with this Lord Chief Tom and I
love you I'm not just one company not to
die to make good games or any type where
any type of developer going away is not
good especially in the triple-a space
it's not good acceptor life
yeah just lead up don't engage with
these practices you don't like I don't
like blue crates I'm not gonna get with
them I'm not gonna pay for whatever I'm
buying the game Dell I'm buying it
behind the game like it oh I might get a
loot crate see listen this goes to my
little cell phone thing I'm telling you
I'll be playing these little cell phone
games and I have one move and I can beat
this boss all I need to do is buy these
coins so I can get extra time yeah I
might spend my dollar you might get it
I'm sorry it depends on how I feel at
the moment I'm shallow so what about
twenty effects mmm you know like I said
give you the competitive advantage this
is kind of the same topic this is a good
question what's worse me Bose find them
what has it given you any sort of
competitive edge yes like I said you can
run around you couldn't run around that
single player game and be God if you
want because of it so it's okay to walk
amiibos to like Seattle Arc motif not
much point Metroid did lock an entire
mold did you buy the game I brought the
game and that resale value is serious so
enjoyment is something out if he sells
it
so 4,000 they still did it so what your
amigo city streets an evil life Dan all
know that lordy need the extra the
Esprit endo games but let's get back
good trick I feel with Jessie okay I'm
with solve on his rate first ever in
salute you Lord what's up um yeah I
think like I said at the end of the day
we see what's happening in history this
is where the industry is going like it
or not I mean we have the whole adage
vote for your wallet I hear it I get it
the only thing I'm warning these social
justice work is on line is just okay you
have to respect someone else's time
someone else's money what they choose to
do with their money in the privacy of
their own house is their business you
know saying so at the end of the day you
can stand against it there's nothing
wrong with it you can boycott this
nothing wrong it I just want us to be
careful of the personal attacks I'm
saying I'm seeing a lot of personal time
saying people being disrespected
personally as a man because they bought
again like that's crazy Ted that's easy
to me like if that let's say like I'm
gonna use this example I'll meet you at
it if that person was waiting for shadow
of war his entire life and that's his
right and he works 9 to 4 why are you
watching another man's pocket we're
talking about at the lower blackboard
continue just want us to be careful of
it with this practices we don't agree
with
don't say shadow cycle I love you bro
thank you for coming through appreciate
you I like what y'all doing over there
playing xbox um yeah so just like its
yes things like this is like yo you know
I mean like just respect that man's
purchase what he wants to do and we
respect you for not wanna do it if you
want to make a petition and if it's
something you feel is so egregious and
you want to shut it down there has been
cases like Forza right where the
community was upset they didn't like
with the VIP system they went and turned
ten changing around so if there is
options where the change can't happen I
care I get people you know I'm never
gonna tell you to boycott again I don't
care if you do okay if you come at me
from our purchase I'm going to tell you
to uh to go somewhere I don't care I
would say something else but you know
the best way I don't I don't I don't
even think voting for wallets enough
these days because there's too many
ignorant people that don't know what's
going on that's gonna buy it anyone so
your I will say a super-wide hundred
that you're right they are the minority
and it's really the casuals were falling
for it right in casuals that are gonna
those are the masses it's a white house
is gonna affect the way that you combat
this is as you know most hardcore gamers
that's the people that's gonna you know
speak casuals aren't really going to
take a stand unless they frank convinces
them into doing something that they
don't really comprehend or understand
but a lot of hardcore people you know
they they follow a lot when it comes to
the gaming industry so they're more up
to date with something like this the
best way this is the reason the PC
gamers get what they want all the time
he's you gotta be very vocal like what's
more effective you not purchasing one
game for $60 or the community manager
for EA gets on ground thousand no no no
you're talkin see that's how you affect
change like you've got to go to these
community managers managers you've got
to go to that what you call its reddit
you know I'm saying that titles let it
like a sample for example like a destiny
or whatever look you've got to get in
there and that's when it actually
more of a positive effect but when
you're out here attacking these dudes
you know I'm saying for buying a game
with a like or an amiibo whatever the
hell it is and you call and you kill the
double standing like why the north's
offset people out here you know
attacking people for one thing yet they
buy an xbox live and they do it you
can't have it both ways and even and
even that like if you think about it if
you're not buying into Xbox Live and PSN
and you're not doing the lucra stuff or
whatnot so that means the assumption is
that means you're a PC gamer right so if
you're a PC gamer and your PC gamer then
if you're buying through Steam you're
contributing to the biggest monopolies
in digital distribution and all exactly
right let's get real so box team they
say you go to Green Man gaming well
you're you're buying a game at a 20% 50%
discount at launch which nobody else
like it's again every point that every
point that you have if you look at it
from a different perspective you're full
of it so he said you got to do both hold
that money hostage and make them
brutally aware of the reason why you
know certain games that might be
effective but the games that they're
doing this the games that people are
talking about the games that are getting
all the momentum on the Internet
they're not gonna care about maybe a
couple thousand people not buying their
games look at Star Wars it's sold like
what like 15 million units Star Wars
Battlefront I think it said that we
talking to them but not everyone still
buying again I think the issue comes
down to for the people who are anti Luke
rating saying it's gambling and stuff
like that then figure out a way to do
days right now they brought some places
looking and it was like yo we want to
ban this practice and I was like no way
not taking it out now that could be
resolved I'm sleeping in bed now
Jamie has to raise your children for you
now you know when it comes down to it a
developer is gonna be more scared of you
of you bashing his game on Twitter and
saying you don't like this you know
really you know how to do with a hashtag
everything then he's gonna be scared of
you not buying his game because the
public outright can really matter you
can destroy a game if enough people bash
on a game because of something they
don't like before the game even comes
out how many times are you gonna buy
something if you ads like three stars
then you're gonna look at this that the
star rating you're gonna look at the
people that have a problem with anything
you don't walk away from it if it's just
one person who says oh no I had a very
bad experience with it because the x y&z
nine times out of ten you won't buy that
product and then you will click that
this this this review was helpful and
you'll move on to the next and you will
go to that five-star product that didn't
have the negative reviews so understand
exactly where attic is coming from and
also understand with sovereign it's
coming from but but we have to
understand this guy's and I mean it's
getting way out of control you know when
people giving people personal attacks
over um because of big companies um
voice your opinion in the forms that
will allow you to be heard that's it
simple if you're voicing your opinion
towards somebody who's made a purchase
of a game you're trying to belittle
somebody for their purchase I believe
that shame on you and I don't see
integrity a net sucks um what they need
to do is they need to get to the polls
get to the blogs get to the the avenues
that allowed them to be heard you're not
being heard screaming at Tommy who
purchased this game I'm sorry
so I don't care I walk around with
what's going on get out of my way one
last what aspect to bring it to the
Lords of reference to Lucas and to
finish this to go what about the whole
aspect with the game I'm seeing a lot of
stuff or saying that this is affecting
kids you know they went to the SRB in
these guys and you say hey can we get
these blue box completely out you know
my kids are affected this is that
basically saying that to the letter of
the law lupus
they said it's an aura G system that's
to the letter of the law you know what
the funny thing is don't be saying this
oh it hurts my kids about it are about
m-rated game I'm like you're you're
hopeless just go because of shadow war
go away always watch your kids make sure
that you don't have any auto pace or the
stuff on your
somewhere they can open a new crate and
it immediately allows them to purchase
something thank you Mike
grasping corporate to control exactly
and make sure that doesn't happen
but it teaches them gambling I mean kids
come on man I will say that you know
it's a stretch to say that it's gambling
but I will say I understand where the I
understand right now cuz my thing is
what about what are you saying to people
who say like you know I didn't know
Little Jimmy was gonna Xbox and he
bought you know it's come down to better
parenting you need to watch your kid I
mean I don't disagree then loot boxes at
their core especially the pay ones are
you kind of scratch that itch for people
that have that sort of addictive
mentality where they like to that's
called more more more and more they know
what they're doing they know what
they're doing at the same time it's not
their problem that you leave your kids
alone with that sort of stuff you need
to watch your kids what type of parent
puts their credit card on the kids
xbox their profile listing rock out
Rainbow six hasn't spent an extra penny
on all the characters you know Sam
alright Lord Lord Chief Charles he was
like that a stop laughing what's wrong
with you do you now understand it is
only two differences winnings can't be
exchanged for real come see currency one
always wins something so good ossama
Latifah don't want attack just want to
be very clear with the sentiment I want
to be very clear as far as what I
consider habitual lines
Epping type where companies every not
gonna keep pushing they keep push it and
I top their definitely they're out of
their boundaries like just because you
know I ain't gonna boycott or go up
people from boycotting I ain't condoning
none of this not exactly like like we
understand what's going on here we're
not trying to make money I'm sorry sorry
the company has to make money they
wouldn't if you want to pick it up it's
on you they told you it's available if
you want to and if one person gets in
and he gets the advantage she want him
with the opinions this is a hot one
right now appreciate all the feedback
even when you don't agree with the laws
we respect that addict bundles out he
announced to me or we're calling the
bundles right like we are all right just
make again so let me go to he already
bundles are in can you click on it
alright what's like it I've always say
what you it o live
yeah yeah I got you bro but uh alright
so we're gonna be talking about these
four magical beasts bringing out bring
it up there you go there you go whoa so
I agree with the first one well let's
for it let's let's let's break it down
okay we got we got four new bundles that
have been announced okay we got the one
and done halo 5 in the Master Chief
collection then we got the three months
is that three months ago to three months
xbox my pass okay so we got that then we
got rocket League we got rocket League
all right
then we got minecraft which I understand
the Minecraft but I kind of don't
understand the Minecraft because the
last time I checked we already had a
minecraft bundle it was a custom but
they messed up on a rut and priced wrong
but I digress but so let's let talk
about the halo one do you guys agree
with the halo bundle yes yes I mean
halos big still yeah it's the it's their
it's their baby and I'm actually just
before you move on to the next one go
I'm actually impressed that they even
acknowledged master chief collection
exists based on history so I thought
that was kind of cool
all right so then we got the games of
gold in a game pass I agree with this
one I completely agree I don't agree
with that because okay one thing that
three months crap it should be it's
unrealistic to think they're gonna put a
year of this in there so few money so
how many years they can sell that
besides you know Lord unreasonable I
have anything to say
love you daddy bill better you let you
feedback time you know man I like I
really look forward to you every Sunday
I'm not gonna lie
Tommy I'm shallow bro
I will prove Lord flashbacks in the
comment section I think six months would
be a little bit reason abouts in three
months I think six would be good but uh
okay there's no way a year would be in
this one year maybe a year of gold in
three months of Xbox game pass would be
something but I think all of these are
399 correct these are all four hundred
dollars a year there needs to be six
months no no I think for $2.99 mother
$2.99 Lords consents individual vote for
the four that bundle what do we feel
gained a constitution yeah okay 279 its
279 I'm looking at you have the one that
I literally don't understand what are
the Lords think of Brunei in Brunei
rocky super named I can tell you what
happened there I'm gonna tell you what
happened in that rocket League there
somebody slept with somebody to get they
bundle included in this do you guys you
got some receipts to prove that no I'm
just throwing out speculation but I'm
pretty sure that somebody did some
backroom dealings and somebody slept
with somebody to get this I will agree
with locating it it seems a bit weird
cuz rocket League doesn't
you
rocket League I just don't understand
that just me personally I don't I don't
get that one so that this one's a name
for me lost huh yeah it's definitely
name for me I mean I think maybe I don't
know what the sales numbers off of
rocket league on Xbox one but I mean
rocket League was big when it first
launched because it was on PS Plus and
it came out everybody had it um and then
it still continued to so well on
PlayStation and he and PC so I can see
it not selling well enough max and
trying to get it into more homes where
I'll be money doesn't buy the point I
don't know if it's maybe a good point
yeah he said rocket League is promote
purely for the nintendo cross-play that
will put more heavy so is it efficient
now with the rocket League beneficial
that they are going to be doing cross
boy ok so that's a replace that Rockley
woke up in put rocket league became pass
yep yep and completely take that
minecraft bundle off because they
already have a microphone it's not my
fault you prize 100 always more than
should have been yeah replace that with
lucky tales because mainly for the Xbox
one X did you see it running on regular
Xbox situation it was having a hard time
running on X because remember that game
was a VR game and the it is heavy in the
CPU offload and being that the CPU is
only a upgrade it's not even as a boost
as overclock it's an overclock CPU is
really heavy I know y'all look at as a
simplistic game no the VR experience to
that game puts it as a higher CPU
offload is it's not really you know
beneficial for the regular Xbox at all
Lord says Jasna build a px buff to grind
my gears I don't know
we know it's you J's I think you had my
entire panel from classic material box
in heaven we talked about our energy if
those nice to be considered all right so
what my crowd a vote oh yeah name a rock
lean a Minecraft I'm gonna say yeah I
think it's gonna sell it's gonna so it's
gonna sell that's pushing this crap on
everybody yeah listen that their custom
system yeah that's great now you've you
to price to custom system with the
Minecraft you could put that as their
bundle now would be nice yeah so what
okay good push that out there that is
that should even be a thing like that
shouldn't be a thing his tour those
bundles is doing their own thing
and two of those bundles is not the same
they should not be in there right like
carpets should be there and like Lord
addict said that a rocket League should
be in game pass get it out of here like
there was just filler I'm telling you
when you look at the videotape you're
gonna notice somebody did some fun with
somebody to get a bundle in it put my
xbox or continue talking I'm gonna look
up other other bundles that's been out
I'm gonna talk right now like I can say
it I think I know you gonna get well
king with a minecraft show what I think
is the flack Friday is coming Black
Friday at Friday has nothing you gonna
get the real bundles
right yes yeah I mean that's pretty much
that's it I agree with like overall you
know just to put a cherry on it
he's a kind underwhelming to me you know
I'm saying head-scratching yeah very
head scratching the rocket League I
don't know what's going on here like I
can't call that one minecraft to me was
expected halo was kind of expected
they're gonna ride that train you know
to the wheels fall off that I kind of
expected I was like surprised they
mentioned Master Chief and I'm curious
to see if master your collection has any
fixes you don't say but yeah I feel
Forza was a missed opportunity you know
hopefully what Black Friday cop head can
be included come here needs to be out
here it's this is it this is the wind
like we caught member early that my
Lords we call 2017 the Year this is
their win scope a I'm saying this is
critically clean let's go you you gotta
promote these guys I see fill out their
retweeting MHD our Studios and stuff
like that a games well I don't know I
don't know what the financial situation
get those dudes Microsoft does control
it right they control the intro you're
gonna say it oh shout out the rap
there's another thing called G what's up
with that that you know I'm saying like
that's another miss top of the game so
when the game officially is released
instead of going to the preview crappy
program I don't think they would put a
preview program game in a bundle I don't
wait for the go-ahead because they gave
it the way extra long name now so the
game back I see you back yeah low drop
while sitting there I'm still okay I
don't need to share this anymore
and I'm like why isn't that I'll let me
stop sharing this and I was like and
then I looked at
like the fee for the live I was like why
is my icon gone like but that's what you
got to finish up on the UM which call it
the bundle topic lot attic before you
move on which have you eaten chopping a
bit so as we know our Lord and Savior
Xbox only begotten son Phil Spencer I'll
be you actually put out a statement and
on this is in reference to the Xbox one
X and he said the Xbox when X is not for
everyone
he said the Xbox one s will be the
market leader for us and it's the more
affordable console so just again
scarcely we know on the leave the eve of
lean Xbox one launch me x launch we know
it's coming we got it you know one more
month everyone's getting high you notice
a and um he made this comment at a
Brazil game show you know saying and for
all in purposes you know intent purposes
this is correct we know that the Xbox
one X is you know I'm saying kind of
considered almost the elite controller
of the system so to speak right he made
that comparison you know I'm saying now
the question I want to bring to launch
one do we think this is a mistake by him
saying these kind of comments to do we
think Microsoft is under estimating the
whole demand of the Xbox one X which is
gonna lead into my next point which is
about the Xbox when X stock I'm gonna
give it to you right now give me one
second when finish this last one which
is right now a lot of again for clarity
this is UK retailers right are putting
out that their stock for the Xbox one X
is a fraction of what they originally
thought they would get from you know far
as retail is concerned you know some
thought they were gonna get you know
hundreds of units as they requested
based on the man you know I'm saying
again this is not pre-orders pre-orders
are fine but we're talking about walking
in retail that day of right people that
are not us and going to try to pick one
up people
these retailers are saying in the UK to
Haiti they requested like 100 based on
the man they got five units question to
the Lord
based one sales comments based on
supposed Xbox when ex back issues is
this going to be a problem the way
Microsoft is handling this the five
change what Phil Spencer and what the
Microsoft brands doing and what
corporates doing is let's be where I
think they're trying to you know for the
most part I wouldn't say unfairly but
you know besides 2017
I won't wouldn't really say they've been
attacked by the media but you know
they've had every negative thing they've
ever had highlighted by the media like
excessively so I feel like they're
trying to be like yo like you know just
in case if we don't do numbers like we
think and let's let's try to downplay it
that way people were just surprised and
not disappointed mm-hm now here's my
question you like in that case we know
the pre-order sold out in this
tremendous demand right and I'm saying
but do you think they may be making sake
what if there's people that go to a
store in November right they had their
intention to pick up an Xbox one X it is
not available if they didn't preorder
don't do you not think this has a
negative effect as far as the
competition and we all know what the
competition is this ties into bending
knee segments regardless with this is
theirs
they're gonna win November just off
pre-orders looking I need you hey Phil
you're genius bro and when you said it
when you told them hey you know it's not
for everyone we do have a bundle it
could sound a little time matrix you
know type of thing but it's not it's not
it's Phil's now and let me tell you what
Phil did Phil just elevated it to a
place where I want to be part of that
crowd place all right so you have a lead
you have put it in a space where if
somebody ever came over to your house
and you had a lead controller and you
passed him your controller and they've
never touched it
it was like whoa what's this Microsoft
makes yes this is yeah that's a leak
controller oh how much is it 150 that
guy left your house thinking about how
you can get this 150 to go get that
controller because now that guy looks
like I'm cool with the one that gave me
that might work for you but it doesn't
work for all and thank god you're not
the mature blanket over your head and go
to sleep cause I'm liable to take you up
on that back to what I was saying before
I was so rudely interrupted by the and
also he knows that they're gonna make an
artificial shortage all right it's work
for Nintendo to such a degree that if
they can reduce the heart officials
shortage on these systems and they tell
everybody weekly you might be able to
get a couple of copies we're gonna be
trickling in in people are going to be
buying this thing well into next year
the resale value alone on these things
will force people into the stores to
search for these systems so and if you
go to your friend's house and they don't
know the skinny on the system and they
have the system and you see it you buddy
whoa that's that's there's a boost
you're gonna leave that house with that
feeling of I gotta be included in this
elite package as well so I love the way
we're Phil went with it I like the
market and idea behind it create the
artificial shortage narrative too
it and also make it feel like it's a
premium elite thing for you to have it
looking before I pass it I want to ask
you one question now what about I
understand that logic and I totally see
what you going I'm not knocking it
my question to you is what do you see
what do you say for the people like I
said these retailers that are saying
they requested a hundred now what about
the people who actually come in on store
November 7th there's only five units and
there's nothing to pick up fight you
know runs the risk of majority of
customers were going to gravitate
towards the cheaper console games for
some excellent endo switch PlayStation
bundle or whatever it is like it's not
one shelves let's be ro here what are
with the switches so what it did if it
didn't have soda on launch when it did
there are no doubt facts got to push out
to make you keep telling us if this is
what happened stop then if it's okay but
but no it's you're comparing a
completely different scenario to a
completely unrelated one wish your point
let it's look the reason that the switch
works the way it does because it's got
exclusive you can only get it on that
platform and it's the hot thing right
now and it's it's it doesn't have
which doesn't have a and inversion like
the s does with the X okay fax you have
to just get this people gonna be there
and they'll be like where's the X
you know we're talking about X's right
now about the supply demand and whether
or not it's going to hurt the overall
scenario of the egg
walk in to be like yeah I want an Xbox
brand we're talking about casual people
come from PlayStation I go walking
they'd be like I need an X they'll be
like well um we don't have an X but we
got a pro well I'll take that
that's what's literally gonna happen
like yo you know what then they sold the
pro oh well but we're talking November
in PB I said at the beginning they're
gonna win just offer pre-orders alone at
least 200 for pre-order thing again
that's the narrative big high with this
system from the very beginning that it's
not for everybody the moment at e3 that
the system wasn't announced at $400 they
continued that narrative so you're
saying that it's at this point it's
still not for everybody it is what it is
like I don't I didn't expect anything
different from them maybe they or said
all along they're gonna push that as
narrative so the S is what they're
pushing as they're that the console is
gonna sell the most in terms of the
stock in terms of the stock I could I
it's a detriment it definitely is a
detriment because with with the
excitement that you're seeing I honestly
I expected the project Scorpio addition
to sell out I honestly didn't expect the
pre-orders for the base ex to sell out
and in most places they're sold out like
I think maybe Best Buy still has it but
I don't even know that that guarantees
you're getting it day one um but most
places are sold out in terms of just
their base regular Xbox one X is it
what something I did not expect so
looking at that I would say yeah they
have a problem that they don't have
enough stock in store for people to come
in and buy it you need at least in these
big stores and the targets you need that
Lisa listen I'm trying to get my resells
let's go does he go yes that's what he
could fund his of his LG of his flat
screen that the LG fast it goes up on
the wall yes Weibo Dinko says they're
still available in Europe continue so
it's one of those things like when you
look at the fact that the base
pre-orders are almost out again they may
still have them in certain places you
know there's some demand for that you
need to have a decent amount of stock in
stores anywhere from like 60 to 100
consoles and stores that's what I say
like you know it's better to be safe
than sorry because they they don't
they're not in that position is like
addicts said like they they don't have
that killer puts them in a position
where they can be like oh you know we're
being said right and with now we just
admitted the segment before we're not
fans of these Xbox 1s bundles right
these bundles seem uninspiring
right so my question is how do you
expect them or the lords expect them to
win the month with limited stock we know
Nintendo's ramping up production
we've got articles saying they're
talking like two million - whatever it
is it on deck you know and we still have
Sony let's not act like Sony's not a
factor out here right so we still with
all these things do those these two
Lords of mine hello an addict in legit
deal without a shadow of a doubt stand
behind my word okay let's say let's
throw out like you know numbers from you
know previous years last year they sold
a little over a million you know just
the regular exes we're not the ex is
obviously the standards okay so let's
say they they do around that because
it's the holiday you got Black Friday
you got all that so you got that let's
say they sell half of that you know just
half and so that's let's say they sell
600,000 Xbox one X's and I think that's
under balling it I kind of think it's
going to be a little higher than that so
I mean we have to like 1.5 1.6 and like
that is way over what the competition
sold last year but obviously the
Nintendo switch wasn't here last year
but my only thing with the switch is I
think a lot of people are gonna go out
and buy switch when Mario comes out
mm-hmm and I think they're because
they're gonna want that they're gonna
want that bundle when it drops and
that's gonna be in October the end of
October and that's not gonna be in
November MPD's remember oh no you know
you're right you could from a
technicality standpoint it's what is it
then okay so is that like very last week
oh they're you know they're gonna get
these bundles because of how cuz of you
know the shortage rate that people
expect from switches they're not gonna
wait a month later the majority of these
switches of those bundles are going to
be purchased in October so and then I
have another issue I don't know house
what's a switch going switch Nintendo
saying they are you know doubling
production it's like okay so you want to
sell a million in Black Friday like can
they can they have
the stock to sell all of November and
Black Friday because I don't know what
they can do that because they can
literally sell on Black Friday but they
sold all on just on Black Friday again
so I don't understand
I'm not means nothing to me unless I see
the stock but this is the thing though
like throughout the whole year this is
why they had these artificially honestly
again throughout the whole year you
would have consoles right before big
Nintendo releases before splatoon before
before metallurg art before arms the all
sudden consoles appear in in stores
everything else they've been stockpiling
when it's a into millions because they
would not come out with a number like
that if they didn't feel confident they
could come close to hitting that so I it
to me they've been stockpiling oh you
know I mean they can stockpile but what
is their version of what they have they
put out a number of how many they have
what what their stockpile have a number
on how many Xbox one X does it how many
how many switch so just on pre-orders
just on pre-orders I don't know how many
of the Xbox one original so just on
pre-orders what is like 2.53 I don't
know I don't know if it's like 1.7 1.8
MPD won the first month lost ever since
then pretty much like when it comes down
to it it's like I get that it's a hot
product and I get that you know the
switch is gonna do well ain't no doubt
in my mind it beat PlayStation no doubt
in my mind and if you know if it beats
put Xbox it's not like a oh really
there is there is a possible ooh they
can't I just don't think is hi I think
sorry will be dead last even with the
market arise evil but at you know people
don't realize how like how much your
pre-order and how much a new product
sells right out the gate if we are
talking December I'd be like yo there's
probably no chance that Xbox ones in
December but we talked about the launch
month it'll be a different story if it
came out the end of November it was like
the 2018 I've put it at the beginning of
the November mm-hmm was to begin to know
my Tom oh you mean Xbox when I tried is
gonna be significant alright it's only
going to be whatever you're gonna be
enough you know when you got a consider
you gotta consider the S the S is
probably gonna sell double with the X
elves and when you put them both
together its power over us screen casual
no your rocket League is casual um
Michael Arnold Mike rats cos Ken what's
popular people owe you 20 a to cuz I do
you know Lord Jesse says he thinks
they're gonna drop the the s is $50 per
wrong for Black Friday which is a good
possibility so someone walks in sees 250
especially the game pass they see three
months a game past three months of Xbox
Live go I don't want to buy either one
of those they're like well what does
what does game pass have they're like a
hundred games you like put it in my cart
look he's a good argument you knows I'm
just glad the sound of the Lord's coming
around
like I respected cuz two months ago we
wasn't realistic and I like that you've
been on realism train I like on the
Tendo stock and to be honest with you
they can have stock to go to Black
Friday in your defense you've always
said that your whole concern was that
you didn't believe Nintendo would have
just I don't think that the whole fried
idly with and the blood like there's a
difference between having stock for
Black Friday in having stock for Black
Friday
I like boxy likes a good point he says
minecraft and rocky league or cross play
with switch it's been tend to have like
ourselves to push it so you think maybe
that might be like a little side hustle
about Microsoft to eat off the switch
successor like there's great elite comes
out I believe in that month I believe I
believe Rockley comes off a switch like
there's a dip like let's say what I mean
by are they gonna get through Black
Friday's I meant are you know you got
that panel you walk in there they open
the doors to Walmart you walk in there
they got that panel switches how many
panels are those do they got in the back
you'll see we're gonna see I just know
mostly when I look quickly they got like
six or seven panels of Xbox one SS and
panels of ps4s how many switches are
they gonna head back
oh no they already had that no day
that's going to invest by and all that
that's going down they already have to
marry your stuff up on deck that's a
fact the kiosks is in there so the
Nintendo's on their game with that I got
to give him that
shout out to be money with him his point
was like don't sleep on Sony they could
still drop the pro pricing for the
holidays well Sony is still holding
these cars the price of the Florida I
agree with the Mario thing but how much
is that bond or are they gonna use in
October when Mario like a few days an
actor you act like it's the middle but I
heard
people are going to pick it up when is
that when is the Rhino come out and but
didn't sell to have the same carryover
effect where it came out or one of them
games that they wouldn't even know sorry
about at the bat of my bet you're right
it's not the whole is not mariokart
mariokart can you take the end of the
month prior right one that NPD for the
short week and their decision next month
when their point is $60 tighter to a 300
dollar machine we're talking the same
thing we're comparing the the MPD says
of a software comparing it to a hardware
I mean but so that's that people been
waiting to push switch hardware I'm
saying is a lot of those cells are gonna
be in October you know they obviously
there's some little no one's gonna get
in only the hardcore buying it under
27th Oh whenever it comes out that only
the hardcore everybody else is gonna
wait to November everybody else is gonna
try it how many Mario buns are gonna be
available for that's the question for no
question how do we know that these Mario
bundles aren't gonna the majority
obviously I think you know Nintendo
don't keep a little bit for Black Friday
you know that they're gonna try to keep
some of that stock but at the end of the
day that's their biggest title are they
going to hold all of them back how much
are they gonna hold for that is right
person is claiming that they're on deck
for that whole purpose they be saying
all the time to think that they increase
in stock they increase in stock and we
still see [ __ ] sold out in two days
achieve commie that was hilarious you
see some actual harassment we don't
notice that that's not you'll see shout
out the tick last
you'll save me money a good cow they
definitely hit it on the head plus one a
trip show no Lord Tim dog double-check
Leslie yeah he double-checked that jazz
it doesn't carry over no doubt shall
attend pre-k he's like how many
customers are gonna buy a new 4k TV 4
console for you cheap ones the cheap
ones it's $400 yeah that's putting no
HDR you have no agents all your box but
this is probably all jokes aside we all
can it's gonna be fun to see what
happens this is probably one of the most
competitive people go coming we gonna
close this thing out we just got we're
gonna pay the bills right quick and get
this thing out but it's gonna be a farm
up so that great time guys it's gonna be
good
alright so real quick new ILP poll via
Lord addict with the success of games
like cuphead Zelda Dark Souls
blood-borne hell-blade etc especially
zelda especially companies the entire
format of the Zelda format are we seeing
a resurgence in Hard difficulty games
becoming popular so a yes real game of
skills are back in a big way be no
difficult games don't equal good games
that is the question
those are the choices the IOPS what can
I put a third on there sure what's there
Co 4:30 and you change the route code so
you can see the game itself we see you
baby we got some cookin that's good
what was it you should put down there
the third with the fourth what should be
or do you game enhance
get past the difficulties preciate Yahya
Ayyash drove please hit that like
subscribe to the IOP incentive Network
media outlet
stick around for what I say next visit
ik GA page we got our motive force
brothers on deck or Monday so they next
anomic so you can check them out link is
in the description all that stuff helps
to learn looking yes I'm not you want to
close out you said area define people
find you was good old yeah attic channel
you can find me on Twitter
Lord I ope you can find me on xbox live
rim to kill PSN when I'm ever on there
room to kill and you can find me on
YouTube gaming addict I've been doing a
livestream of a shadow horse you can
find me there thanks for everyone come
and make make sure you like that button
uncle I expect at least 40 on this thing
so make sure you hit that like button
Louis already what could have find
people find you you guys don't
understand that we're here we're here
that have these discussions man it's and
to get at each other but in a playful
and I go for the Lord it's funny it is
trendy people can find me on to their
Lord sob I hope you know Xbox Live and
PSN at being sovereign listen hey guys
I would tell you right now [ __ ] this is
actual factual troops this week right
now after I leave out of here I'm going
upstairs to my playstation I'm gonna
log game I'm gonna play for PSN for for
a month
understand because I got a match coming
up with hip hop I'm using
performance-enhancing gamer I got I got
it I got a match with him and listen
listen listen I'm gonna give you all the
parameters later after the fact after I
clean his clock I'm going to I'm going
to break them down and it's gonna be all
on videos gonna be on twitch will be
livestream and we will be able to be
again after this again dude but this
game to go to lore King David's Twitter
and tweet and the word the letter L we
all know we all know this is just kind
of messed up that you got a team number
that's nice so listen man why should do
with the quinine
so watch them
now I'm going to break this down we've
got the base parameters match up in
place for all the people to the chat is
to check it for the match up the base
parameters in check Lord King is down
for that smoke for whatever it is
whatever we just waiting for Lord
hip-hop to grill and one other two
parameters as far in the stream we're
gonna stream it you know I see the fans
in the chat on the table so nobody
garbage pickup times going down so we
got we were just working update the
aisle or plastic with the details the
specifics of streaming all of the
parameters we gonna have that out there
for y'all I appreciate this take David
OTW right correct sir yes sir I got more
Twitter it's gonna be live we're gonna
be pro
this thing huh thank you for everyone I
take you to chat we both don't represent
that for short oh oh you already know
football is here off the bridge is
better I agree